PAGE.
WE WILL BRING THEM TO YOU SOON
AS WE GET THEM.
FIRST, TIME FOR TONIGHT'S
BREAKING NEWS OPENING MONOLOGUE.
TONIGHT WE START WITH EXPLOSIVE
NEWS FROM CATHERINE HERRIDGE,
THE MEMOS JIM COMEY LEAD TO THEM
MEDIA THAT BECAME THE CATALYST,
HIS DESIRE FOR THE APPOINTMENT
OF SPECIAL COUNSEL ROBERT
MUELLER.
THEY WERE MORE WIDELY SHARED
THAT HE PREVIOUSLY DISCLOSED.
LAST YEAR COMEY TOLD CONGRESS
THAT HE LEAKED THIS MEMO TO HIS
FRIEND, PROFESSOR DANIEL RICHMAN
OF COLUMBIA UNIVERSITY.
TONIGHT SOURCES ARE REVEALING
COMEY'S CURRENT LAWYER, LONGTIME
FRIEND PATRICK FITZGERALD.
YOU REMEMBER THE SCOOTER LIBBY
CASE, HE WAS ALSO GIVEN THIS
POTENTIALLY CLASSIFIED
INFORMATION.
THESE DOCUMENTS.
AND SOURCES ARE ALSO CLAIMING
THAT COMEY MAY HAVE LEAKED THE
MEMOS TO YET ANOTHER UNNAMED
INDIVIDUAL.
MOMENTS AGO HERE'S HOW JAMES
COMEY TRIED TO EXPLAIN THESE
LEAKS HE NEVER TOLD US ABOUT
BEFORE.
>> I SENT ONE MEMO,
UNCLASSIFIED, STILL
UNCLASSIFIED.
TO MY FRIEND DAN RICHMAN.
ASKED HIM TO GET THE SUBSTANCE
OF IT TO THE MEDIA.
I WROTE A BUNCH OF MEMOS ABOUT
MY INTERACTIONS WITH
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND I WAS WHAT
WAS CALLED AN ORIGINAL
CLASSIFICATION AUTHORITY AT THE
FBI MEANING I HAD THE TRAINING
AND AUTHORITY TO MAKE DECISIONS
ABOUT WHAT SHOULD BE CLASSIFIED,
WHAT SHOULDN'T.
SOME OF THESE MEMOS I DECIDED
SHOULD BE CLASSIFIED.
FOR OTHERS, I WROTE THEM, AND I
WAS CONFIDENT THEY SHOULD NOT BE
CLASSIFIED.
THOSE FOUR, I KEPT A COPY AT THE
FBI AND IN MY PERSONAL SAFE AT
HOME.
AFTER I WAS FIRED, I PUT
TOGETHER LEGAL TEAM OF THREE
PEOPLE, ONE OF WHOM WAS
PROFESSOR DAN RICHMAN AT
COLUMBIA UNIVERSITY.
AFTER I ASKED HIM TO GIVE THIS
INFORMATION TO THE MEDIA, I GAVE
MY LEGAL TEAM FOUR MEMOS THAT
WERE UNCLASSIFIED.
I SEE NO CREDIBLE CLAIM BY ANY
SERIOUS PERSON THAT VIOLATED THE
LAW.
>> Sean: IT IS LIKE OBAMA
SAYING NO SERIOUS PERSON THING
RUSSIA COULD EVER HAVE TAMPERING
IN OUR ELECTIONS.
CONTRARY TO WHAT COMEY SAID, WE
WILL HAVE MULTIPLE CREDIBLE
INDIVIDUALS INCLUDING JOE
DiGENOVA SHINING LIGHT ON
COMEY'S MISDEEDS.
CNN WENT ON TO PRESS COMEY ABOUT
HIS POTENTIALLY ILLEGAL LEAKING.
AMAZING.
WATCH THIS.
>> YOU DID LEAK MEMOS.
IS IT OKAY FOR SOMEBODY AT THE
FBI TO LEAK SOMETHING, AN
INTERNAL DOCUMENT, EVEN IF IT'S
NOT CLASSIFIED.
>> THERE IS A WHOLE LOT WRONG
WITH YOUR QUESTION.
I DIDN'T LEAK MEMOS.
I ASKED A FRIEND DUKE
COMMUNICATE THE SUBSTANCE.
ONE UNCLASSIFIED MEMO TO THE
MEDIA.
I WAS A PRIVATE CITIZEN.
I WAS NOT IN FBI EMPLOYEE.
>> IT WAS A DOCUMENT YOU HAD
WRITTEN WHILE YOU ARE FBI
DIRECTOR.
IF YOU TELL SOMEBODY DON'T GIVE
THEM THE DOCUMENT BUT TELL THEM
WHAT'S IN IT, IT IS STILL A
LEAK.
>> NOT TO GET TANGLED UP, I
THINK OF A LEAK AS AN ON
CLASSIFIED -- DISCLOSURE OF A
CLASSIFIED DOCUMENT.
>> Sean: REMEMBER IN JUNE OF
LAST YEAR, JAMES COMEY MADE NO
MENTION OF THIS DURING HIS
TESTIMONY BEFORE CONGRESS.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> DID YOU SHOW COPIES OF YOUR
MEMOS TO ANYONE OUTSIDE OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE?
>> YES.
>> TO WHOM DID YOU SHOW COPIES?
>> I ASKED, THE PRESIDENT
TWEETED FRIDAY AFTER I GOT FIRED
THAT I BETTER HOPE THERE IS NOT
TAPES.
I WOKE UP IN THE MIDDLE OF THE
NIGHT ON MONDAY NIGHT BECAUSE IT
DIDN'T DAWN ON ME ORIGINALLY
THAT THERE MIGHT BE
CORROBORATION FOR OUR
CONVERSATION.
THERE MIGHT BE A TAPE.
MY JUDGMENT WAS I NEEDED TO GET
THAT OUT INTO THE PUBLIC SQUARE,
SO I ASKED A FRIEND OF MIND TO
SHARE THE CONTENT OF THE MEMO
WITH A REPORTER.
I DIDN'T DO IT MYSELF FOR A
VARIETY OF REASONS BUT I ASKED
HIM TO BECAUSE I THOUGHT THAT
MIGHT PROMPT THE APPOINTMENT OF
A SPECIAL COUNSEL.
SO I ASKED A CLOSE FRIEND OF
MINE TO DO IT.
>> WAS IT MR. WITT IS?
>> NO.
>> WHO WAS IT?
>> A GOOD FRIEND OF MINE WHO WAS
A PROFESSOR AT COLUMBIA LAW
SCHOOL.
>> Sean: HE WAS UNDER OATH.
WAS HE WITHHOLDING INFORMATION
FROM CONGRESS QUESTION OR DID HE
LIE BY OMISSION?
REVELATION SURROUNDED WITH
WHETHER THEY FIRED FBI DIRECTOR
ACTED IN AN UNETHICAL AND
POTENTIALLY LEGAL WAY AFTER HE
WAS FIRED.
TONIGHT WE CAN CONFIRM THAT THE
OFFICE FOR THE INSPECTOR GENERAL
IS INVESTIGATING JIM COMEY, THEY
DISGRACED FORMER FBI DIRECTOR.
FOR MONTHS ON THIS PROGRAM WE
HAVE BEEN PREDICTING THAT JIM
COMEY COULD WELL IN FACT BE
FACING SERIOUS LEGAL
CONSEQUENCES.
EARLIER THIS WEEK THE PRESIDENT
WAITED.
HE WROTE "JAMES COMEY ILLEGALLY
LEAKED CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS TO
THE PRESENT ORDER TO GENERATE A
SPECIAL COUNSEL.
THEREFORE THE SPECIAL COUNSEL
THAT WAS ESTABLISHED BASED ON AN
ILLEGAL ACT.
REALLY?
DOES EVERYBODY KNOW WHAT THAT
MEANS?"
EVEN CNN'S TOP LIBERAL LEGAL
ANALYST, HE IS WEIGHING IN.
EVEN HE ACKNOWLEDGES THIS IS NOT
LOOKING GOOD FOR JIM COMEY.
>> WHAT IS THE PRESIDENT
IMPLYING?
>> WHAT HE IS SAYING IS THAT
WHEN JAMES COMEY TOOK THOSE
MEMOS THAT RECOUNTED HIS
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE PRESIDENT
AND GAVE THEM TO PROFESSOR DAN
RICHMAN AT COLUMBIA UNIVERSITY,
THAT WAS AN ILLEGAL LEAK,
ESPECIALLY SINCE HE KNEW RICHMAN
WAS GOING TO GIVE TO THE PRESS.
>> ARE NOTES ABOUT A
CONVERSATION WITH THE PRESIDENT
TAKEN BY A PRIVATE CITIZEN, ARE
THEY CLASSIFIED?
>> THEY MAY OR MAY NOT BE.
IN FACT, WHEN THE
ADMINISTRATION, OR CONGRESS
RELEASE THOSE, SOME VERSIONS OF
THOSE MEMOS COME OUT SOME MORE
BLACKED OUT.
I THINK JAMES COMEY ACTUALLY IS
IN A PRETTY VULNERABLE POSITION.
JUST BECAUSE SOMETHING IS NOT
MARKED CLASSIFIED DOESN'T MEAN
THAT AFTER THE FACT IT COULDN'T
BE RETROACTIVELY DESIGNATED
CLASSIFIED.
I THINK COMEY MAY REALLY HAVE A
PROBLEM THERE.
>> Sean: MAY HAVE A PROBLEM.
POTENTIAL LEGAL JEOPARDY NOT
STOPPING COMEY FROM LIVING IT
UP, CASHING IN ON HIS NEWFOUND
FAME AND FORTUNE, THE TRUNCATING
FORMER FBI DIRECTOR THREW
HIMSELF A BIG PARTY AT
WASHINGTON, D.C., AN APPROPRIATE
VENUE CONSIDERING MANY OF THE
GUESTS WERE FROM THE MAINSTREAM
MEDIA.
LET'S HOPE JAMES COMEY MADE A
GOOD IMPRESSION.
WE KNOW THEIR BOOK TOUR IN THE
MEDIA BLITZ IS ONE BIG TRYOUT
FOR COMEY'S FUTURE CAREER, IF HE
WANTS ONE, AS A PUNDIT ON
CONSPIRACY TV, MSNBC OR FAKE
NEWS CNN.
ONE MORE BREAKING STORY.
FOX NEWS HAS LEARNED THAT FORMER
NEW YORK CITY
MAYOR RUDY GIULIANI HAS NOW
TAKEN OVER DISCUSSIONS WITH THE
SPECIAL COUNSEL ROBERT MUELLER
ABOUT A POSSIBLE INTERVIEW WITH
THE PRESIDENT.
RUDY GIULIANI PUT OUT A
STATEMENT THAT READS IN PART
"THE PRESIDENT HAS PRODUCED
1.2 MILLION DOCUMENTS THAT IS
HISTORICALLY UNPRECEDENTED.
WE BELIEVE IT PRESENTS
OVERWHELMING PROOF THAT THE
PRESIDENT DID NOT COLLUDE WITH
REGARD TO THE 2016 ELECTION."
THAT'S WHERE IT WAS SUPPOSED TO
START.
ACCORDING TO SOURCES, THE
PRESIDENT IS OPEN TO SPEAKING
WITH ROBERT MILLER AND WRAPPING
UP THE INVESTIGATION.
WE ARE GOING TO ANALYZE THE
DEVELOP INSULATOR IN THE SHOW.
MY ADVICE:
MY ADVICE: UNTIL ANDREW
WEISSMANN AND OTHER ANTI-TRUMP
AGENDA DRIVEN INVESTIGATORS ARE
FIRED, NO WAY DONALD TRUMP
SHOULD DO THAT INTERVIEW.
ANDREW WEISSMANN, DESCRIBED BY
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" AS
MUELLER'S PIT BULL.
HE WITHHELD EXCULPATORY EVIDENCE
MULTIPLE TIMES, SEVERAL
HIGH-PROFILE CONVICTIONS,
OVERTURNED ON APPEAL.
BUT NOT BEFORE RUINING THE LIVES
OF TENS OF THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE
ESPECIALLY AT ANDERSEN
ACCOUNTING.
NOW WE TURN TO ANOTHER MAJOR
BREAKING STORY.
JUDICIAL WATCH TONIGHT HAS
RELEASED HUNDREDS OF PAGES,
BRAND-NEW FOR THE FIRST TIME
UNEARTHED EMAILS FROM HILLARY
CLINTON'S ILLICIT EMAIL SERVER.
WHY DID IT TAKE THIS LONG?
HOW IS IT POSSIBLE
HILLARY CLINTON WAS NOT CHARGED
WITH MISHANDLING CLASSIFIED
INFORMATION BECAUSE SOME OF THE
NEW EMAIL SHOW THEY WERE
CLASSIFIED.
WE KNOW CLINTON SERVER WAS
LIKELY HACKED BY MULTIPLE
FOREIGN GOVERNMENTS, AND NOW
MULTIPLE UNCOVERED EMAILS
TONIGHT CONTAIN INFORMATION SO
SENSITIVE UNCLASSIFIED, THEY
WERE TOTALLY REDACTED.
INCLUDING THIS EMAIL EXCHANGE
BETWEEN PRIME MINISTER TONY
BLAIR, CLINTON, AND OTHER
STATE DEPARTMENT OFFICIALS
ENTITLED "MIDEAST PEACE."
ANOTHER COMPLETELY REDACTED
EMAIL.
IN THIS DOCUMENT, EVEN THE
RECIPIENTS WERE REMOVED.
THE TITLE OF THE EMAIL WAS
"PLANNED."
OTHER EMAILS REVEAL SOME PRETTY
EVIDENCE THAT THE CLINTON
STATE DEPARTMENT WAS IN FACT
ACTIVELY COLLUDING WITH THE
CLINTON FOUNDATION AND THE
CLINTONS CONSTANT OBSESSIVE
MONEYMAKING SCHEMES.
IN ONE DISTURBING EMAIL,
CAMPAIGN OFFICIAL RETRIEVED A
REQUEST FOR, IN 2010, ASKING FOR
ADVICE HOW TO GET THROUGH TO
BILL CLINTON ABOUT BIG MONEY
OFFERED TO SPEAK ABROAD.
WAS IT RUSSIA?
WHERE WAS IT?
THE EMAIL WAS FORWARDED TO A
STATE DEPARTMENT EMPLOYEE AND
EVEN HUMA ABEDIN HERSELF.
DURING HILLARY CLINTON'S TIME
WHEN SHE WAS SECRETARY OF STATE.
REMEMBER CHRISTIAN SASUKE?
THE NAVY SAILOR RECENTLY PART OF
MY PRESIDENT TRUMP ONLY AFTER HE
WAS FORCED TO SPEND TIME IN
JAIL, SENTENCED TO A YEAR IN
JAIL FOR MISHANDLING SIX
PICTURES HE WAS PROUD OF BECAUSE
HE WORKED INSIDE A U.S.
SUBMARINE.
HILLARY CLINTON IS MISHANDLING
TOP SECRET EMAILS.
THIS NEW RELEASE ONLY ACCOUNTS
FOR A COUPLE OF HUNDRED EMAILS.
WITH THE 33,000 SHE DELETED AND
ACID WASHED AND HAD DEVICES
BEATEN UP WITH HAMMERS.
NOW THEY CLINTONS REALLY WANT US